what do you see as the connection
between consciousness and bigfoot
that's a big question
the bigfoot phenomenon is a rabbit hole
it's a rabbit hole covered in ice with
greaseport over top of it
it's really slippery
and once you go down that rabbit hole it
leads off to a hundred other rabbit
holes
so
the question you ask is interesting
because
the journey of someone who wants who's
interested in that phenomenon starts off
looking for a big hairy egg
that's really smart
if you dig deep enough you leave that
school pretty quickly
it's no longer gigantopithecus the big
hairy ape that's really smart
and instead you start going wait a
minute
and then you keep having a whole bunch
of weight on minutes with attributes
various attributes
including potential
uh um
telepathy
and uh
cloaking and
all sorts of you know
various
versions of manipulating energy as well
so i think
consciousness and bigfoot
where it lands first of all nobody has a
freaking clue what these are
but the phenomenon is big enough
hundreds of years to thousands of years
hundreds of cultures all saying the same
thing by the way and tens of thousands
of anecdotal references
including sightings
some things there my question is
never mind just bigfoot
if that species is out there and i can
come back to them what else is out
there i mean you can't just go okay so
there's bigfoot i'm going home now say
well if there's bigfoot
what else
and a lot of possibilities
open up
for example i think that
the potentiality is there for this
species nicknamed bigfoot but for
example sasquatch and whatever the
different names of that
to be a culmination of all of these
attributes people talk about
which would include
uh
psychic abilities the ability of
telepathy
which would include cloaking abilities
which now one gentleman had a theory
that i still think holds some weight is
what if it was simply a species of
intensely savant autistic
individuals and their savant autism
gave them such extraordinary ability
of hide and seek
and on top of that a savant ability of
telepathy and a survivability and they
had
they understood how to manipulate their
own energy their own life force energy
to me all of that's possible if we're
talking about
the potentiality of the human mind but
the minute you throw bigfoot into it oh
that's just nonsense exactly
how do you know it's not a species
that's way ahead of us okay they don't
compose symphonies they don't build
airplanes and cars i get that
that doesn't mean they can't do all
these other things so i didn't really
answer your question because i don't
know the answer to
the comparison of consciousness and
bigfoot what i'm suggesting is they
if they exist they are
in a realm of existence that we are far
from
grasping or understanding and they're
farther ahead than we are on certain
levels just way behind us in other
levels
why i'm asking is less you don't
disparage the bigfoot topic i don't
disparage the ufo topic even though
plenty of the scientific community would
and
i i'm pretty sure i was inspired by you
but either way
so if
sorry for stealing that from you
stealing your own that's okay
okay either way when i was listening to
i believe it was some of your podcasts
or your commentary on some of the
bigfoot episodes before which one am i
bone to pick with you man
which i'm gonna put as an aside right
now i'm gonna tell you that as i fall
asleep
i used to listen to your shows
and and then
right and i have insomnia and right when
i'm about to fall asleep you'd play the
harmonica and i'm just cursing you and
i'm just wishing man i wish someone
would timestamp when those harmonicas
are so that i could start it from right
after either way bracket that i was
listening to and i believe you said
something like okay i went out to the
woods filming for bigfoot i think this
is way after the series you're filming
for bigfoot didn't occur so you thought
you know
there are stories that they can hear
what's going on with the cameras or
sense it in some manner so why don't i
turn the cameras off perhaps even do
some meditation exercise which is why i
brought up consciousness it's a
meditative exercise
and then you saw orbs and then i think
when i was listening to you said i can't
talk about it yet because you had just
gone through that experience and you
were processing it now am i correct
and if i am correct can you just
reiterate to the audience correctly what
i just perhaps incorrectly stated
no that was all correct that was uh from
the portland episode it was the last
thing i ever filmed uh it was outside of
the full series but it's on youtube now
yeah
what occurred can you talk about it now
well yeah i don't mind really it it's
it's not that difficult to be honest
with you but the full story it's really
it's the story of of um
the potentiality of of mental telepathy
and this particular species you see
when i was in tennessee in the episode
in tennessee and you want to go back and
watch that episode for example
uh and i've told this story uh i told it
just recently on
uh sasquatch odyssey a podcast
bottom line was that i was walking on
the trail on the way out and um never
ever before in my life have i ever
experienced any kind of psychic or
telepathic phenomenon of any sort
whatsoever um and it wasn't high and i
wasn't drunk and i wasn't tired
and i'm walking i'm walking out and i
just had this
powerful
voice
speak to me inside my head
and um
[Music]
so much so that after the fact i
actually went in to see a counselor to
make sure i wasn't schizophrenic because
it hit me that hard i thought i got to
know what's going on here you know and
the counselor reassured me that no
you're far from schizophrenic don't
worry about that what what you received
was a gift and you should just celebrate
that fact would be really aware of that
and then it happened another two times
and then for the portland one that
you're referencing what happened there
was
i'm not i don't think i said this in the
show but
um
first of all i put my energy my thought
energy out there telepathically to the
sasquatch in that area that i was told
were there by a woman who has a
telepathic communication with them she
says
so i i you know said you know i'm coming
to meet you i did this for about a week
ahead of time and i started to
uh uh at one point feel like i was
getting
an answer if you will in my brain okay
fine so now i
yeah so now i go up there
and i go out in the bush and i'm and i'm
the orb thing had happened
and uh later on i'm just sleeping on the
ground and i was starting to doze off in
that little crackling fire going
and all of a sudden i felt
a very
warm and actually felt a bit soft and
furry so it could have been anything
but it basically
went over my ankle and flipped my ankle
enough that it woke me up and i jumped
up immediately and it felt like a
nice big warm hand flipping my ankle
over and i jumped up immediately i
didn't see anything fast forward to the
next morning we're walking out we run
into the lady again and we're planning
on anyway we anyway we see her
i did not tell her this
and she says
she called him guardian so she's she's
given
i was speaking with guardian and he told
me that during the night he came over
and touched you
and what do you do with that
she just that was the next morning she
said that to me after it actually
happened and i hadn't told her
mm-hmm
and
those things
have happened to me about four times in
my life
without er
forcing it lots of times nothing happens
something to remember dude sometimes you
tell these stories people think oh
shit's going on all the time but
most of the time nothing's ever
happening see these are occurrences that
have happened over a number of years
i've had four telepathic experiences
anyway so that's what happened though of
that particular show and i i don't think
i i at the time was ready to talk about
that on camera and i didn't mention it
because if i mentioned it people go he's
losing it
right and i'm screwed
not so much during ridicule
no it's not the ridicule i fear it's
their inability to handle the full story
and yes i'm belittling them when i say
that yes i sound a little condescending
when i say that but screw them if i just
say hey yeah pikmin talk to me
all the chuckles starts like okay you
know what but i could say that to a lot
of people who go really tell me what
happened
that's the person i like to share with
you know
okay it's okay so let's say a week prior
to you going out and experiencing that
orb you were doing some exercises where
you were trying to contact bigfoot via
intention
and meditating something like that
more via psychic outreach like
specifically speaking so i've done it
several times
and and nothing's ever happened but a
couple of times i have gotten an answer
one time it was actually rather quite
funny
i would go on a hike so if people are
wondering how to do this i mean i would
go on a hike and i will just if i want
an interaction i will just put it out
there and just say you know i'm coming
out i'm gonna be hiking
in an area you know don't know if
anybody's even there but if someone is
there i would be welcoming in love to
have some kind of interaction
and then often as i
and
nothing okay and i just go as you go
like
one time though
bam in the middle of my head
all i got was
no thanks for sleeping
i mean it's just the craziest thing and
again remember the first time this
happened i went in to see a counselor
and i've only had this happen four times
in my whole life okay
but i tell you it is the strangest thing
ever when it happens it's so strong
anyone who who is who has this as a
skill in their life will just go yeah of
course that they wouldn't even they
would accept this conversation with zero
judgment
now these four times it's occurred to
you were they each single sentences just
like no we're sleeping or were they so
the paragraph i'll give you the i'll
give you i'll give you the script sure
the
the first time was
we're right over here
if you want to meet us stay the night
to which i replied this in tennessee to
which i replied
because the first time anything like
this ever happened in my life and i was
scared and the hair was up on the back
of my neck i had never felt that
and i said i'm not ready
and they
said that's fine
and they walked away
and i
okay
that was in my mind
that's cool when they said we're here
did they give you a location or they
said here and it was implied they were
near you
both the location was basically the hill
right over there that i could see from
about 150 feet away
that's pitch black i'm in the dark
and they're they're right and i and
the image in my brain that was seared in
my brain was of a large hulking male
figure and a small child
in both in classic bigfoot look okay if
you will
and that really freaked me out um and
nothing and then i think a couple of uh
well no actually a few months went by
after that one the next one was a little
more menacing
um it was during a meditative process on
the texas bigfoot episode and that one i
never told anybody on camera but there i
did get during the meditation stage i
got i gotta uh yeah yeah get get get
ready get ready for this was kind of
sort of the message and it felt menacing
and dark and i didn't like it and i
didn't i just kind of no
no no not going here
the third time was the
uh in oregon and it was the answer in my
brain was simply
no thanks for sleeping and the fourth
time was the portland portland episode
where where basically this particular
being said
um
yeah yeah we're here we're ready for you
you know and uh and that was a wonderful
experience so am i crazy uh am i how
many are these are they hallucinations
is it lucid dreaming is it blah blah
blah blah blah blah i don't know but i
know that in all instances i was wide
awake
very sober very straight and
not
trying to make this happen in my brain
and i've tried many many other times and
nothing happens
but these times there's a sears in the
middle of your brain you just
it's just you can't not hear it you know
when the first time you had a back and
forth or at least you said one statement
which is i don't think i'm ready
did you say that in your mind do you say
it out loud how did you say it yeah i
say it in my mind and so someone's going
away oh yeah sure they'd speak english
sure sure no what they do is it's a
process of your mind deciphers for you
what you're supposed to understand and
to me that if i was chinese it would be
it would be in mandarin you know or
something
so
so uh
yeah yeah so so so yeah it's it says
that yeah so you gave your intention
like hey i'm not ready currently okay
now when they spoke to you
all of these times were they instantly
understood or were they understood
linearly like when you read do you
understand the first word the next one
then the next one and the next one or
was it all at once they said that
sentence to you
interesting question
the the sentences were short enough that
the distinction would be too hard to
make
i'm not sure that i could decipher it
linearly or in a linear fashion or if it
was all at once it was just too short
okay and as an aside the reason is that
some people when they speak to other
beings or
let's say even they have an encounter
with god it's as if
all of that is said to them like that
and it's not like it's like when you
read one word you don't read each letter
you read the word instantly
if i if i was forced to make the
distinction that is what i would say i
would say it feels like it's all at once
it's just that the statuses were short
so it
same thing sort of thing
is it all right if i ask you a couple of
details of the orbs of what the heck
happened there okay so firstly how large
were the orbs and what color were they
where did they come from when did they
come why
well you won't be able to answer why
well i mean i was uh we were uh devin
and i because devon was with me on that
one we were sitting and i just heard
devin go
hey les come here you've got to look at
this
and i and i something like that and i
get up and i walk over to devon he was
10 feet away 15 feet away
and about 15 feet away from him
were to
hovering
orbs
one the size of a golf ball one the size
of a pie plate the pie plate one was
much more fuzzy and less distinctive the
golf ball was more focused in if you
will
they stayed hovering there
and you could see like gentle hover
in their movement
but in the same position
for i want to say a good 15-20 minutes
enough for us to look and go is there
car lights flashing off something is
there local i mean we're in the middle
of the forest right
our eyes are you know i mean we're all
clear again straight
you know no no uh
we weren't smoking anything or drinking
anything sober
and
i think what's going on there
if this species truly exists this
phenomenon is actually something
is that one of its attributes is its
ability to manifest or ability to
manipulate its own life force energy and
in doing so it has a physical
manifestation which is the big hairy
creature we see that smells and shits
and eats and screams and throws rocks
and the other manifestation which
potentially could be in as light energy
which we would then translate as being
an orb
and and also the other message that we
got the next morning from the woman who
is an empath and a psychic with these
beings that she said
that
she was told that some of the others not
the one guy that supposedly flipped me
over at night but some of the others
came to look at us in the earlier part
of the night and that's when the orbs
were there
okay what color were the orbs both the
same color too
like you're sure whitish
have you heard of any connections
between ufos and bigfoot
of course i've had people i've heard
people say that often often often often
my first craziest experience was on the
mountain in radium springs and there was
a scenario that happened there that i do
not believe i mentioned on the show
because i didn't want to confuse the
viewers it's the other thing right
sometimes you
you're forced
before you feed somebody filet mignon
you've got to get give them a taste of
meat first all right you know and so uh
that night um i looked over in the skies
and i saw these four big lights so they
were massive huge
and they were all lined up and they
could not have been airplanes but they
were up in the sky and they were just
there
for 20 minutes
and then i went back and i'm not sure
where i went to go maybe i went to get
my camera
came back they just they were gone they
disappeared and i've never seen anything
like that in my entire life and i'm just
like oh my god like i'm thinking this is
but at the time i'm just like
oh this is cool what the hell is at the
time i'm like what the hell is that and
that was the night you were with devon
or that was a different night
no this is the night i'm alone this is
on the mountain top of mountain mountain
in radium springs but i was one of my
surviving bigfoot episodes
that was the night after those lights
where i felt
i had something come in and sit on top
of me while i was trying to sleep and
everybody's going to say that's old lady
syndrome that sleep paralysis i get that
i'm familiar with that that is not what
i felt that night it felt
like somebody was sitting on me with
very large buttocks and then that next
morning of these apples i put on the
tree they all disappeared and the camera
was filming didn't catch anything they
just disappeared on camera you know the
whole night was freaked out but my point
is that it started with those big four
lights in the sky and you said you know
connection of ufos to bigfoot i don't
know
i really don't know the thing about it's
the world of the phenomenon of
sasquatches
over on one side here it's a big hairy
ape that's smart and on this side it's
aliens and everything in between you
know able to travel dimensions that's
what you meant by the slippery rabbit
hole with mud and so on
yes although more so what i need but
what i mean by the rabbit hole is is my
line of whoa if there is sasquatch what
else is there
have you heard of skinwalker ranch
of course yes yeah okay so see when i
was researching a bit about ufos then i
read about skinwalker ranch and the fact
that there
have been observed portals whether or
not this is true there's been observed
portals perceived portals and then
sasquatch coming out and then this is a
place where there's plenty of ufo
activity and poltergeist activity as
well it's a strange confluence of all
these unexplained phenomenon
and you know when
as a scientist when you hear about let's
say well what's consciousness have to do
with
someone's soul phenomenon the scientists
would always say there's this tendency
in us to say unexplained phenomenon here
unexplained phenomena well they're
related somehow because they're both
unexplained and that's a foolish mistake
but when it comes to
bigfoot and ufos well let's just say
bigfoot in ufos it seems as if it's more
than just the connection being drawn
because there's question marks over each
in other words okay well you want a riff
on yeah well i nominate i just think
that um
i just think existence is so much bigger
than our human
little human brains can can
can comprehend and and the thing is it
doesn't scare me
the rabbit hole doesn't scare me
it's just like yeah of course i mean
we've had so much about ufos that if a
ufo landed in new york tomorrow
everybody would go oh yeah i figured
they were there
we get a lot of that you know like oh it
becomes the de facto of course the
aliens exist i knew that
who didn't know i knew
but we don't really know
um
i just think my mind has always been
is this possible
and the answer to every single
question that that's asked on in my mind
is could be yep
i'm quite open to it and here's the
thing that doesn't scare me and the
problem is that it scares a lot of
people
and and and certainly a lot of religious
people it really scares them because
then you're going to bring satan into it
right so to me
none of it
i just don't feel a fear and i'm not
being machismo i just think
the possibilities are endless and isn't
that awesome
have you felt the fear and then you
managed to overcome it or just
temperamentally you don't feel the fear
when it comes to that
temperamentally i don't feel the fear
uh and also i'm well aware of the fact
that
if i was face to face with an alien
tomorrow
uh
he's got a he or she or it has a huge
advantage over me of course yeah right
so what am i going to do about it you
know what can i actually do go grab my
ak-47